I
Heard over and over and over and over and over in the first couple of trainings that I took and I've bought a lot
Of programs have taken a lot of courses
I kept hearing the same thing the riches are in the niches the riches are in the niches Nick
You've got to find some crazy niche that you know
no one's ever thought of it's it's you know, and I heard niches like
Let's think of a couple examples
Well drilling and chicken coop building and just these crazy things and feng shui feng shui
Whatever that one is and I thought in order for me to be successful
I had to find some crazy niche that no one had ever
You know thought about tapped into whatever and then I was gonna just take it vertical and I was gonna make millions dollars
that's what I thought okay, and
What I realized is that although I know you can make money doing that
I know people that have I
Also know and this is how I made my money is you can also make your money by going into boring
Regular niches that you've already thought of that you've already heard of that work
We know they work because other people are making money in them and you focus on finding cities
That are untouched, right?
So instead of obscure niche its obscure city
And so what I argue is instead of the riches are in the niches
I believe the riches are actually in the cities
So what you need to realize is as you're going through and we're gonna pick our niche in this section first of all
We're not gonna overthink this because a lot of people get hung up wouldn't it should I go into oh my gosh
You know the world's ending. I don't want to make the wrong move. No, we're not gonna do that
Okay, but you either need to go into a really obscure niche that you can then go into most any city because no one's done it
Or you do what I did which is you go into some regular niches that we know work
okay, and I'm gonna go into some of those are getting a couple of examples and
You take these regular niches and you spend your time finding cities that nobody has thought of heard of or would even
Consider going into but you know because I'm gonna teach you that this this this and this all match up and you are going
To have success. Okay
So you need either need to pick an obscure city and a regular niche or an obscure niche
And then you can go into regular cities
All right
so it's when it comes to niching there's a couple of criteria that you need to look at and that I
Really really really really strongly feel that need to happen
so
Number one is the niche that you select needs to be medium to high ticket now the way that I define this is
Where oh by the way, we're talking about what the customer charges to the the homeowner
Okay, so customer goes in your customer goes in talks to the homeowner performs the service performs the job
What did they charge that needs to be medium to high ticket?
So I would consider medium to high ticket at the bare minimum a thousand dollars. Okay gross
So they're charging the right in an invoice for a thousand bucks up to
1015 K and I'm not gonna go too deep into this
But I actually don't like it to go much past that because then we get into a long sales cycle
And it's a little bit more difficult to do
However, I would err on the high side rather than the low side and it's very simple
The reason that we do this is if the customer can charge high prices to their customers the homeowners
There's gonna be more money
For us to charge higher retainers
It's also gonna be easier for us to justify a higher ticket price when we go and charge them monthly or weekly for our service
Okay
Second thing when we're talking about niche criteria is there has to be good demand
There has to be good volume and what I mean by that is there has to be a certain amount of people
Actually searching for that service in that city. Okay, because for example
Let's take the niche artificial grass, which actually is a really good niche
It's one I'm gonna I'm gonna explain here in a moment that niche is excellent in some cities
but if you were to type in artificial grass in
For example the city that I grew up in which is this not even a city it's a little town first of all
There's not you know that many people there. But secondly
People there don't spend that much money on their yards
And so if you started looking at the metrics you would quickly see there is not that many searches
There's not that much demand for artificial grass in the city. In fact, I don't know one person in the city
I grew up that has artificial grass. I can't think of one house
So we do need to make sure there is
Good demand good search volume. I'm gonna show you how to do that. Don't stress about it
The third thing is there needs to be no brand loyalty
What I mean by that is with let's take a niche like concrete
Okay, when I got my concrete done, I extended my pool deck. This is last summer. I
Went in and I looked at well, this is actually a little bit different for me because I had some clients
But I went and got a couple of estimates. Okay, and I did not check if they had a license
I didn't have them send me previous projects. I didn't like I didn't care about any of that
I just said hey and I had one of them was my client. I had him come give me a bid
I had a couple other people give me bids. I
Didn't care what they're I didn't even know what the company LLC was called or their their business, right?
So we want those type of niches because when we build a site
That is branded very generically right or unbranded
We want to be able to make sure that people are still gonna call us
So an example of this is like for for like solar
Solar panels, right if you're gonna put solar on your house, you're going to check out who the company is
You're gonna check out the reviews. You're gonna want to see the projects
They've done you want to see the license and this then blah blah blah blah, because that's a huge business
It's a big commitment. So that for example is a niche that is very brand loyal
So just to recap on those two things number one is you want to make sure it's medium to high ticket
You want to make sure there is good volume and you want to make sure there is no brand loyalty
All right
Let me give you some good examples of good niches that I would recommend going into and some examples of bad niches
So good examples
Concrete and these are all by the way
I don't give you examples unless I've made money concrete one of my favorite niches tree service great niche
artificial grass awesome niche spray foam insulation awesome niche
Masonry block wall awesome niche. I'm trying to think if there's anything else comes to my mind
Duck cleaning is is kind of in that gray area. It's a little bit too low ticket. I won't do duck cleaning anymore
It's not terrible. You could probably sneak, you know a decent sized deal, but it's it's an okay niche
I don't love it. Okay
bad examples, okay, so those are good ones bad ones
Dentistry, okay anything like medical like that because people are gonna want to have some brand loyalty solar
Okay, these two I'm gonna share might shock you a little bit roofing
Roofing is pretty brand-loyal. There's so much money in roofing that people are spending ridiculous amounts of money on advertising
They're buying billboards. They got custom wraps in their cars and I'll bet you as you're watching this
There's probably one person if you think who's the roofing boss in my town
There's somebody that comes to mind
Whereas with concrete there's not really like, you know
The guy or the company the girl that's out there. That's like that's the the concrete person, you know
It's there's very little brand loyalty. So dentistry
roofing solar
Another one I found to be very difficult as HVAC. That's a pretty brand loyal deal
Electrician for whatever reason has been not great
So good ones tree service spray from insulation concrete, etc bad ones
Dentistry anything medical roofing solar
Whatever. Now one little caveat is if you're gonna look at a niche like roofing don't do it
However, I have made a decent amount of money in roof repair because it's more niche more niche
More whatever you want to call it then roofing not as many people want to go after it
not as many people care because they're just coming to fix a tile or coming to fix this or that and so those are
The good examples was the bad example
So guys I'm gonna show you a couple of examples of some niches that I have gone into and made some money
Some decent amounts of money in these niches. So
First one is tree service
As you can see st. George tree service
I'm actually what's interesting about this one is I have made over
$20,000 in this specific niche and this specific city. So this website, okay, and
What's interesting is I'm not even ranked number one. I'm ranked one two
I'm ranked number six. Okay. Here's my website. I'm ranked number six website doesn't look that great
I've made over $20,000 here. Okay
incredible, okay that this blows me away my
What's even more fascinating is my GMB. I do have a GMB. It's verified for whatever reason
We just can't seem to put it in the maps. It kind of you know ebbs and flows, but we're still making money
We're making a thousand dollars plus per month for the last couple years. So I'm not complaining
okay, another one that I mentioned as a good example was concrete and
We have you know made a good chunk of change in this niche as well. So st. George concrete st. George concrete
And here you have it. Okay this outside same format. We did get some nice photos taken and
That's it. So those are just a couple of examples. I love concrete. I love spray foam insulation
I love tree service as I mentioned and
You don't need to overthink this guys
What I want you to do is in this module and actually before you move on to the next lesson
I need you to pick a
Niche, okay, and I don't want you to overthink it and I don't want you to spend a week on this
I don't even want you to spend a day on this and I'm gonna tell you right now if you're somebody that's like
Analysis paralysis you're gonna hesitate you're gonna overthink it
I'm gonna just go ahead and tell you pick concrete pick concrete right now pick that niche because it's amazing. It works
I've made tons and tons and tons of money and think about it every city
I don't care where you grew up what village I grew up in what I would consider a village
It's still there was still concrete that people needed concrete. We had we lived on a you know, whatever slab
We had a concrete driveway concrete sidewalk. Everybody needs concrete
So if you're hesitating and you don't know and like oh my gosh, what niche should I use?
What should I go into first do concrete?